hola a todos decían ils board un físico
danés que hizo estudios sobre la
estructura del átomo y la mecánica
cuántica y que ganó un premio nobel en
1922 que un experto era aquella persona
que había cometido todos los errores
posibles en un determinado campo
entonces si ser considerado experto está
bien porque cometer errores está tan
penalizado por esta sociedad si se
supone que es el camino para llegar a
ese experto soy tomás llorente soy
arquitecto llevo más de 15 años
trabajando en temas de la ciudad y los
ciudadanos y quiero compartir con
vosotros esta tarde esta charla una
serie de errores que me llevaron a
descubrir un material junto con ana
blasco que es
100% sostenible y que puede cambiar el
mundo de la construcción nosotros bueno
yo desde pequeño era muy inquieto estaba
todo el día haciendo cosas algunas
buenas otras lo tanto de hecho mi padre
me recuerda alguna vez algunas de ellas
de hecho me decía que me repite todavía
ahora que él sabía que desde pequeño yo
iba a ser arquitecto porque una vez
estaba él haciendo una obra en casa yo
cogí un martillo sin decir nada y volví
muy contento arrastrando el martillo que
era casi más grande que yo y le dije a
mi padre papá y ha terminado mi obra mi
padre me miró así mi hijo ya se echó y
fui muy contento a enseñarles el agujero
que había hecho en un tabique
y luego me fui haciendo mayor pero
seguía siendo inquieto y me metí muy
pronto en el mundo del emprendimiento y
de la empresa fundé la primera empresa
hace 20 años esta empresa tenía todas
las papeletas para salir bien estábamos
importando de japon baterías de móvil de
esas que duraban una semana ahora eso ha
cambiado un poco y a pesar de que
teníamos todas las papeletas para que la
empresa saliera bien esa empresa salió
mal y salió mal entre otras cosas porque
no éramos capaces de aprender de
nuestros errores a tiempo se ha
mencionado en una charla anterior no
merece la pena lamentarse del pasado los
errores son errores del pasado pero solo
son errores en el pasado si no has
sabido aprender de ellos antes entonces
todo esto
me desesperaba cometer errores me
frustraba pero gracias a dios conocí a
nuestra guerra en un programa de
aceleración que se llama lázarus y él me
enseñó una metodología una manera que te
guía para hacer todos los esfuerzos
dirigirlos hacia aprender todo lo que
puedas cuando las cosas salgan mal y
aportar valor cada vez que las cosas
salgan bien para poder seguir
satisfaciendo a tus usuarios a tus a tus
clientes entonces quiero compartir con
vosotros una serie de errores una serie
de acciones que algunas no salieron bien
otras nos salieron mal y junto con aulas
desarrollamos este material todo empezó
ana blasco es ingeniero químico y yo soy
arquitecto ella vive en valencia yo
también tengo mucha relación en esa
ciudad y nos preocupaba las quemas que
se hacen de pájaros en l'albufera que se
producen entre 75.000 y 90.000 toneladas
al año por un lado y por otro lado en
las fallas en los monumentos falleros
que todos conocemos se utiliza
poliestireno expandido que es un
material de riego
y que produce mucha contaminación cuando
se quema entonces nosotros queríamos
conseguir algo así
queríamos de estos dos problemas buscar
una solución un material hecho de paja
de arroz que evitará que la pájaros se
quemarán en la albufera que es un
espacio protegido y fabricar con este
material los monumentos falleros en
evitando que se quemara el poliestireno
expandido entonces siguiendo esta
metodología lo que hicimos fue salir de
nuestra casa salir de la universidad ir
al sitio a ver los problemas siguiendo
la frase que muy sonriente nos dice
steve blanco sal del edificio no hay
evidencias en el edificio y eso fue lo
que hicimos
que nos encontramos nos encontramos
campos quemados una superficie de 21 mil
hectáreas en valencia que es lic zepa
que es un humedal protegido a nivel
mundial dentro de la lista de los
humedales ramsar y que los agricultores
queman la paja de arroz incluso con
gasolina como vemos en la imagen
esto nos conmovió nos nos llamó a la
acción
éramos personas pequeñas haciendo cosas
pequeñas como se ha dicho antes pero ya
podemos decir a día de hoy que hemos
evitado que agustín es el agricultor que
está en esta foto junto con anna haya
quemado en paja de arroz en un par de
hectáreas y haciendo un cálculo rápido
es todo el oxígeno que a ello vamos a
respirar en los próximos entre 7 y 8
años con lo cual vamos haciendo acciones
pequeñitas
entonces decidimos pasar a la acción
dijimos vamos a ver qué podemos hacer
con nuestras propias manos con nuestros
pequeños recursos para evitar que esta
paja se queme en la albufera y el
poliestireno se
sé que en una falla imaginaros el reto
hacer una falla con pajas rojas como si
decides construir un coche con cosas que
te encuentras por la calle igual que
nosotros encontramos la bajada rocen
albufera siguiendo esta metodología
decidimos hacer el coche como se ve en
la parte de abajo de la imagen haciendo
pequeñas acciones que cada vez aporten
valor a nuestro producto como lo hicimos
en un principio diseñamos un material
que fuera moldeable queríamos que los
artistas falleros pudieran sentirse
cómodos utilizando este material que es
natural que es derivado de la paja de
arroz y que no contamina para eso
hicimos una serie de pruebas hasta que
dimos con una composición que con tus
propias manos lo podías moldear eso ya
aportaba valor
después queríamos que fuera fácilmente
portable que los artistas pudieran hacer
en un principio muñecos en dos
dimensiones y que lo pudieran también
cortar con sus propias manos evitando el
uso de maquinaria complicada esto nos
permitió hacer muñequitos porque
queríamos que acompañarán a la falla
cuando pudiéramos hacer la falla a
tamaño real luego también queríamos que
fuera recortable que fuera plegable que
se pudiera pintar esto nos permitió
hacer una serie de muñecos pequeñitos
este prototipo se llama serón hay algún
vídeo muy divertido en youtube sobre
esto y nos permitió llamar la atención
de unesco valència unesco es una
asociación que ha proclamado las fallas
como patrimonio inmaterial de la
humanidad pero no gratis hay condiciones
y una de ellas es contaminar menos y con
esto llamamos atención y de hecho este
material está contemplado como un como
un material que es propicio para las
fallas en valencia por último con ya con
el material moldeable que se puede
pintar que se puede cortar y se puede
pegar hicimos una pequeña maqueta para
ver si ardía de una forma espectacular
suficiente para que nos permitieran
a ser la falla en un entorno real y lo
conseguimos esa es la falla que
conseguimos hacer con nuestras propias
manos que se hizo en la plaza de la
mercè en valencia justo al lado del
ayuntamiento
todo esto lo hicimos dos personas
cuatro meses si tenéis en cuenta los los
plazos de las fallas esto es una locura
y porque lo conseguimos primero porque
teníamos pasión porque utilizamos esta
metodología que lo que hace es limitar
la capacidad de equivocarte mucho y
aprender mucho de los pequeños errores
que cometes
eso no significa en absoluto que no se
cometan errores de hecho
se nos quedó esta cara cuando en la
primera iteración buscando que nuestro
material fuera moldeable dimos con un
material que era muy moldeable muy fácil
de usar pero que no ardía imaginaros si
hubiéramos seguido la metodología de la
parte de arriba de la diapositiva
anterior que no hubiéramos hecho estas
pequeñas iteraciones comprobando todo
cada semana prácticamente hubiéramos
construido una falla y no hubiera ardido
imaginaros eso en ese momento nos
tiramos de los pelos yo de forma
figurada
pero siguiendo esta metodología solo
perdimos una semana imaginaros esta
situación estábamos investigando para
fabricar un material para construir una
falla que tenía cárder y desarrollamos
un material que no sabía en absoluto es
como la línea evolutiva cuando de
repente está el homo habilis y sale el
homo sapiens ese es el punto donde
nosotros nos encontramos habíamos
generado a través de un error a través
de una ineficiencia a través de una
situación que no cumplía las
expectativas el homo sapiens de nuestro
proyecto era un producto natural
derivado de la paja pero con unas
propiedades muy interesantes y que por
supuesto teníamos mucho que aprender de
ello
no obstante conseguimos hacer la falla
de esta es la plaza de la merced donde
nos dejaron de marras fallan fue una
semana intensa a la de la planta el
mundo fallero hay que vivirlo desde
dentro para entenderlo y conseguimos
hacerlo y este material fue tan bueno
que de hecho vamos a construir la
primera sardina en el entierro de la
sardina del ayuntamiento de murcia
filtro por eso van a santa así que
estáis invitados a venir a verlo
en internet
después de recuperar el sueño perdido
para construir la falla seguimos
desarrollando este nuevo material
nuestro homo sapiens y para ello
decidimos investigar estas propiedades
que son aislantes térmicas y acústicas
ignífugas y decidimos seguir utilizando
esta misma metodología porque seguíamos
siendo las dos mismas pequeñas personas
que estaban haciendo pequeños cambios lo
primero que hicimos fue comprobar que
este material es resistente y duradero
hicimos unos moldes en forma de corazón
eran los moldes que tenían en la tienda
de abajo pero
nos ha servido para hacer unos colgantes
muy chulos y hemos regalado algunos de
ellos y ha sido san valentín hace poco
pero nos ha servido realmente para
validar esta resistencia y esta dureza
del material luego hemos hecho pruebas
de resistencia al fuego con pequeños
mecheros bunsen que hemos fabricado
también nosotros validando que este
material resiste más de 180 minutos al
fuego sin llama sin desprender
humo y sin soltar gota con lo cual tiene
la mayor calificación de un material
ignífugo en el mercado
luego hemos hecho pruebas de resistencia
de pequeños de pequeños elementos hay un
clic se llama joe es el controlador
aéreo de una demostración que hicimos
para ferrovial simulamos una torre de
control de esta altura y pegamos
pastillas de encender barbacoas
simulando que esta torre de control en
una situación real estaría rodeada por
mil toneladas de combustible y resistió
el incendio todas estas pruebas nos
permitieron llegar a hacer pruebas con
un sensor complejo es un sensor
electrónico de movisat es un sensor de
llenado de un contenedor de residuos que
aguantó 45 minutos al fuego y pudo ser
encendido de forma remota desde la base
de esta empresa si veis por fuera está
ardiendo y con un espesor de un
centímetro y medio dentro apenas se
alcanzan 63 grados todo esto siguiendo
esta metodología entonces la conclusión
es no tengáis miedo de hacer cosas y de
equivocarnos haciendo cosas en todo
proceso hay errores
un proceso ninguna investigación sale
todo bien a la primera eso está claro
pero sí que tenemos la oportunidad de
trabajar de enfocar de hacer las
pequeñas acciones en el momento oportuno
para poder aprender de estos errores a
nosotros nos ha pasado a nayo estamos
desarrollando ahora este material en
lanzadera es un material totalmente
nuevo que puede cambiar el paradigma de
la construcción porque ahora mismo
estamos aislando de edificios con
materiales derivados del petróleo como
el poliuretano el poliestireno expandido
este mismo edificio por ejemplo
cualquier otro aparte de ser elementos
derivados del petróleo necesitan para su
fabricación se generan 7 kilos de co2
por cada kilo de producto hechas la
cuenta de cuántos kilos puede haber
alrededor nuestro y nosotros somos un
material que está hecho de un residuo
vegetal una paja de arroz y ha generado
oxígeno durante su vida útil esto nos
permite llegar a un mercado de 60
trillones de euros a nivel global
imaginaros eso de fabricar fallas que
puede ser un mercado
millones a un mercado de 60 trillones
por un error luego esto por supuesto
fomenta la economía circular al fin y al
cabo estamos quitando el la quema
vegetal de residuos de paja de cereal
para aportar valor a un material que
está quitando la demanda de fabricar un
producto derivado del petróleo con lo
cual salvamos miles de kilos ya llevamos
5 toneladas y no perdón 5 toneladas de
emisiones de co2 ahorradas pero estamos
salvando miles de kilos de combustión en
espacios naturales como puede ser la
albufera entonces para terminar solo
deciros si ana y yo hemos sido capaces
de sacar rentabilidad una oportunidad
como decían antes de una situación
adversa teóricamente todos podéis
hacerlo y os digo una cosa emprender es
maravilloso os va a demandar mucho
esfuerzo pero vais a poder hacer cosas
tan chulas como esta vais a conocer
gente alucinante así que hay que
emprender hacer cosas aprender de los
errores y seguir para adelante muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]